bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic leçon imaginons deux billes relié
par un ressort
si l'on s'amuse à déplacer l'une des
deux billes on va étirer et contracté
leur sort ce qui va avoir pour effet de
déplacer la deuxième fille dont notre
univers tous les objets sont composés à
l'échelle microscopique d'atomes
il se trouve que les atomes qui
composent un objet interagissent entre
eux un peu de la même façon que les deux
billes qu'on avait relié par un ressort
deux atomes se repoussent si on essaye
de les rapprocher des satires si on
essaye de les séparer
au sein d'un matériau comme de l'eau de
l'air ou encore de la roche les atomes
sont répartis de façon relativement
régulière
imaginons que l'on puisse déplacer
certains de ces atomes par exemple les
atomes qui se trouve à gauche en les
déplaçant on les a rapprochés des atomes
suivant comme dans le cas des 2 be qu'on
avait relié par un ressort
ils vont donc repousser les atomes qui
se trouvent à leur droite et au cours du
temps ce mouvement va se répercuter tout
au long du matériau
la perturbation qu'on a infligé au début
c'est ainsi propagé dans l'espace
d'atomes en atom
c'est cette propagation qu'on appelle
une onde sonore en fonction du type de
matériau les ondes sonores vont se
propager plus ou moins vite par exemple
dans l'eau les atomes sont plus proches
des uns des autres que dans l'air
lorsqu'on est mais une perturbation
elle va donc avoir plus de facilité à se
propager dans l'eau car les atomes ils
sont plus proches et un style se
communiquent leurs déplacements plus
facilement si on effectue l'expérience
pour comparer on observe que la
perturbation se propage quatre fois plus
rapidement dans l'eau que dans l'air
[Musique]
notre planète est entouré d'une
atmosphère composé d'airs c'est à dire
que tout ce qui se trouve en surface
et constamment entouré d'une multitude
d'atomes sur terre beaucoup d'objets et
d'êtres vivants génère des vibrations
on peut par exemple penser aux ailes
d'une abeille au moteur d'une voiture ou
encore aux cordes d'une guitare en
vibrant de la sorte un tel objet génère
une perturbation régulière qui va se
propager dans l'air en faisant vibrer
ces atomes les uns après les autres pour
pouvoir détecter ces vibrations notre
corps humain dispose de deux oreilles
lorsque la perturbation se propage
jusqu'à notre oreille l'air qui vibre à
l'intérieur va entraîner dans son
mouvement une petite membrane qu'on
appelle le tympan à partir du tympan
l'oreille va alors généré un signal
électrique qui va être envoyées jusqu'au
cerveau pauli communiqué l'information
enfin le cerveau va créer une sensation
à partir de ce signal
c'est cette sensation qu'on appelle le
son et c'est ce qui nous permet
d'entendre au quotidien les vibrations
des objets qui nous entourent à distance
[Musique]
en fonction du type de vibrations notre
cerveau va créer des sensations
différentes d'une part plus la vibration
et puissante
c'est à dire que les atomes vibre avec
une grande amplitude plus le volume du
son que l'on ressent va être élevé si le
volume devient trop élevé
il peut même devenir dangereux pour
l'oreille
[Musique]
d'autre part plus la vibration va être
rapide plus le son que l'on perçoit va
être aiguë ainsi une lente vibrations va
être perçu comme un son grave alors qu
une vibration rapide va être perçu comme
un son aigu nos oreilles nous permet
ainsi de détecter la vibration des
objets qui nous entourent mais cependant
elle ne nous permettent pas de capter
tous les sons en particulier l'oreille
humaine n'est sensible qu aux ondes
sonores qui vibre entre vingt et vingt
mille fois par seconde ce qui veut dire
qu'il est impossible pour nous
d'entendre un objet qui vibre moins que
20 fois par seconde
c'est ce qu'on appelle un infrasons et
al'inverse il nous est également
impossible d'entendre un objet qui vibre
plus de vingt mille fois par seconde
c'est ce qu'on appelle un ultrason
cela dit qu'on trouve dans la nature
d'autres animaux qui possèdent des
oreilles plus performants que les nôtres
ces animaux peuvent ainsi détecter et
utiliser des gamme de sons qui nous sont
imperceptibles
c'est par exemple le cas de certains
c'est assez comme les dauphins qui
utilise des ultrasons afin de
communiquer et de percevoir leur
environnement enfin les ondes sonores
peuvent se propager dans tous les
matériaux car ceux ci sont composé
d'atomes
mais dans le vide c'est à dire en
l'absence de matière et donc d'atomes
les vibrations d'un objet ne peuvent pas
se propager
car pour ce faire il faudrait que leur
mouvement puisse se transmettre de
proche en proche les ondes sonores ne
peuvent donc pas se propager dans le
vide et c'est pour cette raison qu'il
n'ya pas de son dans l'espace
[Musique]